these ukrainians boarding a ferry to
cross into romania are facing a future
they never imagined
many have been living in bombed out
towns in the freezing cold without heat
light and water
now they hope they'll be safe
but the fighting is preventing many from
reaching safety through humanitarian
corridors
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says russian forces are targeting
civilians despite promises of a
ceasefire in several areas of the
country
president vladimir putin says the
ukrainians are sabotaging russia's
efforts to evacuate people
six humanitarian corridors have been
open from mariopol detailed information
about these routes were given well in
advance to the osce the red cross and to
the ukrainians russian forces will be
monitoring them 24 7.
in the capital kiev there is resolve
preparation
i'm carrying out my duty working for my
country thanking our soldiers that's why
i'm here and i'm very proud of it
and clarity about the violence to come
every house every street every
checkpoint we will fight to the death if
necessary no one wants to die but if
necessary we will protect most of all
our children our families
there is now a 65 kilometer long convoy
of russian tanks and armored vehicles
making a steady approach towards the
capital amid fierce ukrainian resistance
we do have indications that this
operation would be unsustainable within
about three weeks from the motion
perspective
in which case that they would have to
consolidate their gains already made
and look to see a way of trying to
freeze the conflict on the current lines
of advance
there are concerns whether a ceasefire
declared by russia can hold to allow
more civilians to escape
the u.n refugee agency says hundreds of
civilians have been killed
six health care workers have also died
according to the world health
organization but the number of deaths
are sure to rise
natasha name al jazeera